i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
let's start with some very important
actually good news today at least sort
of if the problem gets fixed a judge has
ruled that ron desantis's new
redistricting map in the state of
florida is completely unconstitutional
not okay the lines are going to have to
be redrawn and this is very good news
because what was done in florida was
such a brazen attempt to gerrymander to
the benefit of republicans and everybody
tries to do it whenever they get the
opportunity they try to do it there's no
doubt
but this was so obvious and so brazen
that we were if this wasn't stopped by a
judge
then all bets are off so we have a very
good report from axios florida judge
says desantis redistrict redistricting
map unconstitutional
a florida judge on wednesday struck down
a portion of a redistricting map drawn
by florida governor ron desantis and his
staff
a leon county circuit judge lane smith
said i am finding that the enacted map
is unconstitutional under the fair
district amendment because it diminishes
african-americans ability to elect the
representatives of their choice
a formal order is expected today or
tomorrow to ensure the maps aren't used
in november this is a key part which is
not only was this map found to be
unconstitutional
it can't be allowed to be used in
november while a new map is figured out
that's an absolutely critical element to
this
desantis's plan dismantles the north
florida seat now held by a black
democrat
the new maps desantis called race
neutral
make it harder for north florida voters
to elect a black member of congress in
the fifth congressional district where
nearly half its residents are black so
the technique that's used here is if you
have for example in this case a district
where you have a black democrat and
nearly half the residents are black and
you say well this is this is a seat that
as currently drawn is likely to be won
again by this uh elected official what
you do is you split that district up
and you put some of the black folks in
one republican district and some of the
black folks in another so that in
neither district do they have a critical
mass and in this way you can take one or
two seats and in fact when we look at
the map
the whole point of the map as drawn is
to create
a whole bunch a whole bunch of rep easy
republican districts while making it
very difficult for democrats to win and
of course as if you're looking at this
map you will see that in southeastern
florida the miami etc area you have a
number of of blue districts but these
are maps that make it very difficult for
democrats to win anywhere else and part
of the way that this is done is by using
general demographic trends black folks
tend to vote more for democrats than
republicans in florida and you can you
can use that to your advantage
um
a democratic-aligned redistricting group
joined voting rights and civil rights
organizations to file suit against this
map the same day it was signed into law
late last month and fortunately because
this doesn't always happen
it was adjudicated or evaluated
relatively quickly by the judge so
listen
nobody's surprised right i mean this is
this is not only the expected outcome of
ron desantis deciding he was going to
redistrict and and draw the maps himself
this is this is a feature not a bug of
what they do here and the most important
things here are number one that the
judge ruled on this quickly
but number two that the judges expected
today or tomorrow maybe by the time you
see this clip it will already have been
done
not allow these maps to be used in
november and
one of the other aspects of this
is there is a sort of i don't want to
necessarily call it virtue signaling but
it's a sort of virtue signaling were
many things that ron desantis has done
have not been designed to stand up to
legal scrutiny in fact they were
probably done knowing they wouldn't
stand up to legal scrutiny the point
here is
to attempt a whole bunch of stuff
to then be able to use it either in his
re-election campaign which is getting
going now desantis is up for re-election
in november as governor of florida
or it's theorized and the polling
suggests that he may have a shot it's
theorized that ron desantis may try to
run for president
starting with republican nominee in 2024
and so
you know opening florida early to large
sporting events when everything else was
shut down as we were trying to figure
out in 2020 what is covid how does it
work how contagious is it all of these
things he can use that
the don't say gay bill
the event to commemorate the victims of
communism i think it was called which we
talked about earlier this week obviously
unconstitutional congressional maps a
lot of this stuff isn't designed to
stand up to legal scrutiny because it's
not going to but it is designed to allow
ron desantis to take credit for it at
some point later and uh it wouldn't be i
would be shocked if he didn't do it
either
for his gubernatorial re-election
campaign or if he does decide to run for
president in um in 2024 now just as an
update we've been very very closely
following
um
what are the
uh what are what are the betting odds
when it comes to the 2024 republican
nominee and i actually am trying to find
it i don't have it in front of me
uh where was this ah here it is
ron desantis
continues continues to close in on
donald trump and if we look now at last
check
ron desantis was
roughly at 31 cents now it's 32 cents so
the whole point here is
you now have to wager 32 cents to win a
dollar on ron desantis being the nominee
meaning that the higher that number goes
the more likely it is that desantis will
be the nominee this is the closest it
has been
between trump and desantis for as long
as we've been tracking these numbers and
at one point desantis was down at like
11 or 12 and now up to 32.
he has almost caught up to donald trump
in terms of the betting odds we could
also look at uh actual polling it's just
not super accurate this far out
necessarily and sometimes looking at
betting betting odds gives you a little
more information so that's the latest
with desantis and we're going to
continue to follow it i have told you
now so many times when republicans are
obsessed with saying the left is doing x
we should at least explore whether what
they mean is
we republicans are doing that very thing
new headline
republicans fired after possible
ballot harvesting operation in
pennsylvania uh oh
wait a second is this the voter fraud
they've been warning us about
check this out this is a report from
penn live and the philadelphia inquirer
the fallout from the discovery of a
potential republican ballot harvesting
operation in south philly continued
tuesday as two state party officials
two state party staffers lost their jobs
the matter became fodder for attacks in
the republican primary for governor and
lawmakers on both sides
jockeyed to define just what the
situation said or didn't about voting by
mail republican party officials have
fired seamus o'donnell and c.j parker
both of whom are affiliated with the
republican registration coalition the
pack behind the south philly mail ballot
operation prior to his termination
o'donnell and the pack's former
treasurer and republican ward leader in
northeast philly worked as a field
organizer for the state party most
recently on the campaign of state senate
candidates sam orapezza
parker also a republican ward leader
worked as a personal aide to state party
chair lawrence tavis okay they declined
to comment sources who described the
terminations said the party's decision
to cut ties with the two men stemmed
from an enquirer story last week raising
questions about the pac's work
registering people in south philly to
vote by mail listen to this the news
organization found dozens of republican
mail ballots for the may 17 primary were
being diverted to a p.o box registered
to the republican registration coalition
uh-oh
the committee's chairman
said he helped the voters fill out
ballot applications inserting his po box
on the form where voters would typically
write their home addresses though he
maintained he was doing this as a
service to the voters of course and
intended to hand deliver the ballots
once they arrived many of the affected
voters say they don't remember applying
to vote by mail and had no idea why
their ballots were going to lanzalotti
instead of directly to them
one said lanzalotti delivered his ballot
back to the city once filled out which
would violate state
law now
would violate state law they've been
fired they've not yet been charged with
anything if they did this it is arguably
criminal when we say something violates
state law that means it's a crime at the
minimum we need an investigation but the
most important thing here is
they've been talking about this voter
fraud now for a long time
they talked about it for six months
leading up to the 2020 election we found
no evidence of voter fraud fraud fraud
no evidence of voter fraud
meant to or succeeding at
joe helping joe biden steal the election
but given that in the anecdotal cases
where we find this type of stuff
it's almost exclusively republicans
shouldn't we be exploring
donald trump's performance in 2020 even
donald trump's performance in 2016. now
am i being facetious i don't really know
i mean i'm not alleging without evidence
that trump and republicans committed
voter fraud in 2020 and 2016 other than
the people who were caught right i'm i'm
actually being careful and responsible
with my speech but
when all the smoke is coming from
republicans getting caught doing this
stuff don't we at least need to ask the
question
in the mid in the time that republicans
have been saying look at the fraud
committed by democrats which doesn't
exist shouldn't we at least make sure
that they haven't been committing voter
fraud voter suppression election fraud
on their side just a question and you
can tell me how you think it should be
answered on monday may 30th memorial day
we will be doing a one day membership
special it is our
midterm membership special trying to
build the ranks of membership as we head
into a critical time for the left
hopefully it doesn't go terribly wrong
i would love for you to sign up on that
day we'll send out an email with a
special coupon code on memorial day to
be notified just get our newsletter at
davidpakman.com go to davidpakman.com
sign up for the newsletter and then you
will be notified on memorial day of how
to avail yourself of this great
membership discount
one of the fastest growing crimes in the
us is identity theft and there's a new
victim every 14 seconds this has
happened to me before i've talked on the
show we got hacked it was costly it
wasn't a good feeling and that's why i
now protect myself with aura one of our
sponsors protecting your accounts and
devices gets complicated because you
need a bunch of different tools and aura
combines them all into one app identity
theft protection
fraud monitoring password management
antivirus all in one place they monitor
email addresses passwords social
security number bank accounts credit
cards if something happens you get an
immediate alert on your phone and then
aura can help me fix it as well aura is
letting my audience try it free for two
weeks at aura.com
pacman with the free trial you can do
things like see if your login
credentials have been found on the dark
web i saw an old password was in four
different data breaches probably
something you want to know and it's free
so you might as well just use the link
down below the david pakman show is of
course a community funded program we
offer an extra show every day for those
who support us through our website at
joinpakman.com you can sign up get a
membership in my estimate is it's like a
45 to 60 second process to sign up with
average computer skills probably 45 to
60 seconds and you'll get an extra show
every day called the bonus show you get
a commercial free audio feed of the show
and a commercial free video feed of the
show about six hours before we publicly
publish these and when we do our town
hall events members get priority access
to talk to me all of those member
benefits at joinpakman.com
and you can get a discount when you use
the coupon code obama
what is better than that hard to imagine
anything better than that sign up at
jointpakman.com all right we're going to
look at a pretty entertaining but also
disturbing clip today this is a clip of
republican senator tommy tuberville he
participated in a national security
senate hearing
and it's on the one hand hilarious
because the guy can't put together a
coherent question or sentence throughout
uh his his opportunity to ask questions
at the same time it's really disturbing
because this is who the people of
alabama selected to send to the senate
so it's hilarious and it's disturbing
check this out the guy can't ask one
question that makes any sense
good morning
director haynes in your best assessment
does russia intelligence closely monitor
our secretary of defense
i think russian intelligence tries very
closely to monitor all of our senior
leaders
okay so that so far we're okay does
russia monitor our leaders fine now look
at where this goes so you believe that
noted that when he or
uh
when he or
said that russia weakens
what and that the u.s will move heaven
and earth to arm ukraine
uh
do you believe that's right he should
say that
yes i think the secretary
do you believe russia blames the u.s
intelligence community for helping
ukraine shoot down a russian plane
carrying hundreds of people
i'm sorry sir can you repeat the
question do you believe russia blames us
our intelligence agency for ukraine
shooting down a plane with hundreds of
troops on board
do you do you think russia blames us for
that
which plane are you thinking of
there was a plane recently that was shot
down russian plane that a hundred troops
you believe that they blame our
intelligence agency for that
i don't know sir okay uh do you believe
that russia blames our u.s intelligence
for sinking uh
their flagship
moskova
do you think they blame us for that i
don't know sir we haven't seen any
director to what extent do you access
that russia believes do you excess i
think he means a set i mean it's i'd i
gen if the if he if this guy has a
reading disability then okay but as far
as i knew he didn't
and he's just struggling to make sense
with english words and trying to put
them together
it is a war
with the west in the united states you
think that they believe you excess it is
at war they're at war with us
russia
has historically believed that they are
in a conflict in effect with nato and
the united states on a variety of issues
including in cyber and so on so you
believe that they're fighting us
they're that they're fighting us as well
as they're fighting ukraine correct
in a sense
their perception yeah yeah because we're
arming them and we're talking okay
general barrier does united states or
ukraine have air superiority over the
war zone which one has air support
superiority i would i would call it uh
senator i would call that an air an
error
standoff right now i mean the russians
can can fly a tactical aircraft over the
line
i
i guess maybe
what he was getting into the direction
of is that
it's dangerous in ukraine like okay so
i'm gonna be as charitable as i can here
about what tommy tuberville was trying
to make uh evident here
um he was trying to make the case that
listen
even if we don't consider that we are at
war with russia
russia does see themselves as being in a
conflict with the united states
and
we as the united states don't actually
have control of the airspace over
ukraine
so
u.s officials are shouldn't go to
ukraine because it's dangerous or
something like
i'm trying to make sense out of nonsense
here uh but what is clear is that our
country is in pretty serious trouble
this is one out of 100 senators
this is not like oh you know
it's just everybody gets to speak at a
school board meeting and it's just a
random person from the community who
doesn't know anything about
anything
this is one of 100 senators random
poli-sci students would have better and
more more coherent questions than tommy
tuberville but this is the guy that
alabama republicans said we want we want
to send him to the senate we get two of
the hundred senators
here's the guy that we want to send
we're in trouble as a country folks
we're in trouble as a country and it is
looking very very ugly
oh speaking of it looking very ugly
you're not going to believe this
donald trump was convinced that china
had a hurricane gun
that they were using to shoot hurricanes
at the united states
let that sink in trump thought china had
a hurricane gun
a rolling stone article
trump kept asking if china was shooting
us
with a hurricane gun
the then leader of the free world also
inquired whether the u.s could bomb
china in retaliation for the alleged
hurricane attack so he wanted to bomb
mexico
and he also wanted to bomb china
look at this
near the beginning of trump's time in
office the then president had a pressing
question for his national security aides
and administration officials
does china have the secret technology a
weapon even to create large man-made
hurricanes and launch them at the united
states and if so would this be an act of
war by a foreign power and if so could
the u.s retaliate militarily
trump repeatedly asked about it
according to two former senior
administration officials and a third
person briefed on the matter
a former trump official recently said
quote it was almost too stupid for words
i did not get the sense he was joking at
all
wow
the sources tell rolling stone that
trump started interrogating national
security officials and other staffers
about the alleged weapon during the
first year of his presidency and it
would pop up sporadically at least until
the end of 2018.
two of the sources recall that as trump
got deeper into the second year he
started to drop the topic but would
sometimes joke about it
the other former senior official said i
was present once when he asked if china
made hurricanes to send to us
he wanted to know if the technology
existed one guy in the room responded
not to the best of my knowledge sir i
kept it together until i got back to my
office i did not know where the then
president would have heard about it he
was asking about it around the time
maybe a little before he asked people
about nuking hurricanes now i have to
tell you
if you believe china has a hurricane gun
it's more logical that you would ask can
we nuke a hurricane like if once
you know how sometimes
things don't things don't make any sense
but they have like an internal logic so
like i'll give you an example this this
is a real example and you might say
david this is nothing like it but okay
if you believe abortion is murder
okay
it would follow from that that you might
say
prosecute women who have abortions for
murder okay i disagree with all of it i
disagree abortion i disagree with any of
it 100 against it against all of it but
i understand if you believed abortion
was murder you might believe all these
other things and tried to do all these
other things okay
a little bit like that if you believed
china had a hurricane gun where they
could shoot hurricanes at the country
it wouldn't be as crazy to be like could
we nuke a hurricane i don't know i
is that almost too charitable to trump
i'm not really sure uh
but this is uh you know uh does the flu
vaccine work for kovid was one of the
things trump asked early in the pandemic
what about injecting bleach you might
remember marjorie taylor green's jewish
space lasers
you might remember when congressman
louis gomer asked the national park
service if they could maybe alter the
orbit of the moon in order to ease
climate change okay this is up there
with that does china have a hurricane
gun and um
the theme here there's really two themes
one theme is
trump constantly
confused and ignorant about just about
everything that's that's one theme and
then the second theme
trump really wanting to know about
bombing all sorts of people remember
early and it was either late in the
campaign or early in the presidency
trump had to be told
why
we can't really have nuking europe on
the table like it just there's all these
geopolitical reasons why you can't we
can't nuke europe it's just not
something that you can do
uh he wanted to bomb mexico and mark
esper had to kind of talk and dissuade
him from doing that in order to go after
the cartels
he was asking about nuking hurricanes as
well as retaliating militarily against
china for what he suspected might be
some kind of hurricane gun in order to
shoot a hurricane the theme is bombing
bombing bombing and it is absolutely and
completely nuts
we will have more on this on the david
pakman show instagram page which you can
find at david pakman show we're going to
take a quick break we've got great stuff
coming up on the show today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
steve kaufman who's a former canadian
diplomat and business executive who
spent the last 16 years learning
languages and encouraging others to do
so with his youtube channel lingo steve
and
lingq.com an app that he co-founded us
it's really great to talk to you i
appreciate you being on
glad to be here so okay i mean let's
let's orient the audience a little bit
uh you you speak about 20 languages is
that correct
right let's say a dozen or so that i
could easily get into a conversation and
hold up my end and another you know
eight or so that i'm in various stages
of having forgotten or learning uh
but i put a lot of effort into so there
are all of these kind of conventional
wisdoms about language learning
including um
after a certain age the ability to learn
a language in a way that would be
close to close to native uh becomes
dramatically diminished oftentimes
people talk about age 10 11 or 12 or
something like that uh the another idea
about the best way to learn languages
whether it's by immersion or with
certain types of programs or whatever
the case may be what can we definitively
say about learning language learning
abilities in humans
well you know i'm not an expert on that
but i think
the goal of learning to speak like a
native in other words to be
indistinguishable from a native is very
difficult past the age of say 10 11.
we've all experienced i mean if you have
an immigrant in the u.s or canada that
came before the age of 12 very likely
they'll end up speaking like a native if
they arrive after the age of 20 they'll
speak very very well they may have a
large vocabulary they may express
themselves better than natives but you
will always detect a little something
there that gives them away so the goal
isn't to speak like a native
in my case sure yeah and in fact many
people don't know that i am not a native
english speaker i actually learned
english i mean i kind of am i learned
english at age six when i moved to the
united states from argentina right um
can you talk a little bit about
the in terms of the techniques you've
found effective for learning new
languages what are they
right so the language has to come from
outside
uh so you can't begin speaking you have
to listen a lot we listen as children
as a six i came from sweden at the age
of five
you hear other people speaking you pick
up on it eventually you start imitating
it you start speaking with mistakes and
eventually you make fewer mistakes
so to me input is the key lots of
listening and reading and at some point
the brain has gotten used to the
language now and and wants to output
wants to say things and we'll say them
wrong but eventually we'll start saying
them right and it's not because other
people correct them we start to hear it
better and better we become aware of our
own shortcomings or gaps and we
self-correct
sure you can correct it has some input
so to that extent traditional language
instruction which focuses on getting you
to speak early and speak correctly early
has it backwards you have to begin by
exposing yourself to a lot of the
language in situations that are
meaningful to you and gradually you will
get better and you'll speak more and as
you speak more you'll speak better but
you know it's not that instruction is
bad
or grammar instruction but it's not
necessary
there are the i don't want to call them
gimmicks but there are lots of programs
that are predicated on the idea of
if you can um
first learn to sum to hear and and learn
and practice saying
sort of like 20
relatively common words and phrases and
then expand that to like a hundred and
that will kind of really place you not
only in terms of vocabulary and some of
the most commonly used words but the the
syntax of the grammar of a language that
that's one of the best ways to start by
taking those specific phrases and words
and looking at that first in whatever
language you're trying to learn does
that sound like a reasonable technique
to you
not at all
but i saw where
i can't remember his name but he had the
four hours work week or something and he
was saying he once you deconstruct the
language you understand how it works i
don't believe that because
first of all anything you learn in the
language you're going to forget so if
you learn them all a certain 20 phrases
you're going to keep on forgetting them
anyway
those very common words and phrases are
going to come up if you're listening and
reading and allowing your brain to get
used to the language the very common
words and phrases are going to come up
you can't sort of isolate them and learn
them you have to learn them as part of
allowing your brain to get used to the
language
some of the sort of structural aspects
okay the verb comes at the end that's
gonna become pretty obvious to you
you're gonna get used to it and the idea
of learning a few phrases i mean i've
tried it uh when i say i went to a
country where i didn't speak the
language like vietnam i got a phrase
book i tried to learn the phrases
hopeless you you just can't it's a
gradual process of of absorbing it's
kind of like a snowball getting larger
and larger as it rolls down the hill you
can't just isolate a few things and
learn them i don't believe that
it would seem intuitive and obvious that
languages that are
more similar to those that we speak are
the easiest to learn i mean for example
uh i
my french is pretty okay and i could
tell when i was in french class in high
school that i had a much easier time
because i spoke spanish so much of
french is similar to spanish when i go
to italy or portugal
i can just speak spanish to a lot of
people and they speak their language to
me we understand each other because the
languages are similar on the other hand
i've tried to learn hebrew
and it's extraordinarily difficult it's
it's a different alphabet it's written
from right to left the the syntax of the
grammar is completely different is that
always the case just that the closer the
language is to what you speak the easier
it is
always the case
the biggest issue in learning languages
is words vocabulary so if you're going
from spanish to portuguese you've got 95
of the vocabulary with french you've got
90 or whatever the number is yeah
english to spanish you got 50 of the
vocabulary because of the common latin
origin of so much vocabulary so common
vocabulary is the biggest
because language learning is about
learning words if we have a lot of words
we the brain starts to figure out how
the language works
but it's the words that we need to have
the other thing is writing system
obviously if it's written in the latin
alphabet i mean i've learned you know
chinese japanese arabic persian now
hebrew i tried to i mean where the
korean where the language where the
writing system is different it's a lot
more difficult because everything is
habit and we're so used to reading in
our own alphabet and even if we
understand how the symbols work in
hebrew
um
until our brain really gets used to
reading in that language it takes me you
got to read millions of words so yes
familia similarity of of vocabulary and
obviously the same writing system going
to make it a lot easier are there
objectively
more difficult languages to learn
regardless from what language you're
coming from in other words i i think
like one question would be if you speak
english what are the easiest languages
to learn that's one question but but a
more another question would be are there
just objectively more difficult
languages
well i'll give you a good example for an
english speaker as i am i find slavic
languages complicated in their grammar
but if you are a speaker of a sli if
you're a polish speaker and you want to
learn you know ukrainian it's not
difficult
because you're already used to that so
the the issue is how different are the
patterns and the words of that language
compared to languages you already know
uh
to me that's uh to try to say okay i
mean right now i'm learning persian and
arabic arabic is more and so they're
both foreign to me arabic is more
complicated arabic is more difficult
it's objectively more difficult than
persian
but it might be because persian is an
indo-european language which arabic is
not they both use the same writing
system
language sorry no no i was going to say
when you
when you start with a different writing
system like those
do you go directly to the written
language or do you not even worry about
that initially and just start with
listening to it and trying to speak
well i always start listening and when i
listen i can't understand obviously it's
just noise so then i start reading but i
read small amounts in the case of arabic
and persian i go straight into the
writing system with chinese where this
the writing system is not phonetic then
i did spend sort of one month listening
and reading in a phonetic you know
opinion or the sort of
romanization of of the chinese
so that when i went to start learning
the characters at least i had some sense
of the language and the words but that's
the only case where i've done that
otherwise i go straight in if it's a
phonetic script you know korean uh
japanese to some extent uh and certainly
arabic and persian i i i know up front
that it's gonna take me a long time to
get used to it so i i look at very short
like on link we have the ability to look
at sentence by sentence so i listen to
the sentence i look at it i read it i
don't remember what that symbol is i
look up the symbol i read it again
everything about language learning is
what seems initially impossible you'll
never get there you'll never understand
if you just keep on putting in the time
you eventually get there so you know
persian in arabic at first it's just
noise and a bunch of squigglies
but if you just stay with it the brain
it's got to trust your brain you're
going to trust your brain your brain
will get used to it
i don't know how much you know about how
language is taught
in the united states in general in
middle school and high school but one of
the things i've observed is that many of
the people who take a few years of a
second language in the united states
don't really come out speaking very much
at all and some of the things i observed
in my high school for example with the
spanish teachers was
many of them were not only non-native
speakers they weren't even really fluent
they spoke with with very poor accents
and grammatically it was like 90 percent
of the way there so okay that seems to
me like a recipe for disaster if the
person teaching doesn't speak that well
it's going to be hard to learn but can
you comment a little bit about how
language is taught to middle and high
schoolers and and whether it's being
done the right way or not
well and even a worse example is the
english school system in canada where
kids have english for excuse me have
french for let's say 10 years and can't
speak ah
and
the thing is that first of all
motivation and the attitude of the
learner is so important so the most
important thing for the teacher is to be
able to motivate the learner we don't
need the teacher to become the model of
the language particularly today there's
so much stuff out there
there's some there's
netflix and youtube and podcasts and
radio and tv we don't need the teacher
to be the model of the language but the
teacher has to motivate the learner you
don't even really need the teacher to
teach the grammar you can look it up if
i want to know the conjugation of a verb
in spanish i can look it up if i'm
curious if i'm motivated so the key
thing is motivation and that's where the
way languages are taught typically is
quite demotivating because you're taught
some rules of grammar you're tested on
it you get it wrong
getting things wrong is not very
motivating if you can spend the time
listening to things of interest to you
reading
getting the language in you
more more students will learn to speak
well some some students don't want to
learn but it's the whole idea can you
increase the number of people who are
motivated enough to learn that they will
actually go out and learn
last thing i want to ask you about very
anecdotally
i'm curious whether
there is a linguistic or societal
explanation for why some folks seem to
be almost like predisposed to better
learn
some languages like english and i'll
give you an example
i've this is very anecdotal and i'm
going to you just for you to tell me
it's only anecdotal or there's something
to it i've met a number of folks from
the philippines when i was in france
when i was in the uk
who
spoke english as though they were native
american individuals and they told me
i've never even been to the united
states i learned english merely by
watching american films and television
shows and kind of teaching myself and to
me they sounded like native american
english speakers is there something for
example about the filipino language or
the people that might predispose them to
be better at learning english is there
something to that
i don't think so i mean we have a lot of
filipino immigrants here in vancouver
and a lot of them speak with a
noticeable accent which they never get
rid of
it's rather the the access to american
tv programs if you go to sweden
everyone speaks english it's not because
they teach english better in their
schools it's because all television
programs are in the original version so
they watch lots of american and british
television it's kind of natural to them
that's part of almost part of the
culture they grow up with so
again it comes back to input
uh you know if you're a if you're an
english-speaking canadian in vancouver
you never watch anything in french
unless you're going to the french
immersion program
the school system is not going to do
much right for you they're going to
teach you a bunch of rules you won't
have anything at the end of it so
it all comes back to
input i mean and people do learn who who
aren't uh you know in in the country
when they on television watching these
uh i'm amazed at these ukrainians you
know that are on tv a lot and they're
being interviewed and their english is
unbelievable yeah and they haven't been
living in the states so if a person is
motivated if a person spends time
listening to the language reading in the
language
much more that's much more important
than any classroom activity
we've been speaking with steve kaufman
you can find his youtube channel at
lingo steve and also the language
learning app that he co-founded at
lingq.com that's lingq.com
steve such a pleasure having you on
today i really appreciate it
i could talk forever on languages
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show all right i love this next story
republican senator lindsey graham has
now been caught on audio recordings from
a little while ago
slamming trump and saying joe biden's
actually good joe biden is the best
person in this
post-trump riot moment that the united
states faced over a year ago this you
have to listen to this stuff to believe
it so let's get right into it new audio
tapes have leaked of senator lindsey
graham saying trump went too far and
plays the tv game while calling biden
the best person to have post january 6.
now these are reasonable comments it's
it's yes trump has gone too far trump
plays the tv game joe biden was at least
a good person to have in that he brings
calm and rationality and and sort of
the opposite of the mania of much of the
right
but the reason it's notable is that
lindsey graham is a republican senator
and publicly he was praising trump and
saying trump's grade and all these
different things with occasional moments
of disagreeing with donald trump a new
audio has leaked of senator lindsey
graham revealing his feelings about
biden and trump graham is heard saying
he thinks biden is the best person to
have after the capital riot graham also
criticizes trump in another tape saying
he plays the tv game and went too far so
let's get to uh some of this um some of
these clips some of this audio take a
listen
we'll actually come out of this thing
moments like this reset
it'll take a while
people have calmed down people
i don't want to be associated with that
so this is from the book this will not
pass by jonathan martin and alex burns
this is where a lot of these leaked
recordings of kevin mccarthy criticizing
trump and others have come from and the
picture that we're increasingly uh
having painted for us is of prominent
republicans
who publicly were 98
or 99 or 100 behind trump but privately
knew how bad he was and we're actually
saying so sometimes let's continue this
is a group within a group
and what this does is there'll be a
rallying effect for a while the country
says we're better than this now what's
fascinating about that before we get to
now he's going to praise joe biden
lindsey graham and kevin mccarthy and
others
they thought they were expecting in the
immediate aftermath of the trump riots
they were expecting that everybody
including the republican trump base
would say
this is too far
this was wrong this was trumpists trump
incited it everybody sees what happened
and they would denounce it but then
internal polling started to say
otherwise internal polling started to
say actually people have fought
republicans have fallen for biden stole
the election
some of them fell for it was antifa
slash black lives matter slash the fbi
who did the riots
they fell for it and then we very
quickly realized that the private
expectations of people like lindsey
graham and kevin mccarthy that the
country is not going to stand for this
we can step away from trump because
everybody's going to they were wrong
and then they had to backtrack here is
lindsey graham talking about
biden being a good person to actually
have uh at this point in time trying to
get the shot right for everybody here so
we can see this okay here we go
totally he'll be
maybe the best person to have right
i mean
how bad can you get it joe biden
graham says
joe biden is maybe the best person to
have
in the aftermath of the trump riots
wow
wow
so if you compare january 6 lindsey
graham to the lindsey graham of today
how stark are the differences because we
should point out
that lindsey graham went publicly said
that he had you know he
he hated the way it ended with him and
trump but he'd had enough
yeah
you can almost hear in his voice
anderson senator graham trying to sort
of play out what the impact of this
attack which as we talked was was still
sort of ongoing as we spoke so there is
lindsey graham saying trump's a pretty
good person for this let me see if we
can get there was one more clip i was
hoping to play
um
i guess i don't have it okay which is
fine but i believe we have the
tren oh okay i have a transcript of the
second tape in a second tape graham
criticizes trump's rhetoric prior to the
riot
he was accused of inciting
quote he plays the tv game and he went
too far here that rally didn't help
talking about primary liz cheney he
created a sense of revenge he created a
sense of revenge so i've said this
before and i'm going to restate it
i believe that
this is worse than being a true believer
um the true believers who really support
trump
they're at least
they're only wrong
and their moral compass is misguided and
we can make a lot of criticisms of the
true believers of trump the false
believers i believe are even worse
because on top of all of the bad things
that they are supporting by publicly
supporting donald trump
they are knowingly
allowing their country to be damaged for
purposes of political expediency or
maintaining access to the office of the
presidency
or maintaining a favorable relationship
with their constituents or whatever the
case may be i think that the false
believers are worse from a moral
standpoint and we can put mitch
mcconnell in this as well to some degree
i mean in the immediate aftermath of the
trump riots mitch mcconnell clearly
expected to some degree
that the vast majority of the republican
base would dump trump but mitch
mcconnell was part of the republicans
who also thought the republican base
would never choose trump as their
nominee back in 2015 and 2016. so he's
been wrong time and time again he's been
wrong every time about
now they're gonna ban and so they end up
having to kind of backtrack and for
someone i mean listen mitch mcconnell
graham they're not political idiots to
some they're a little bit astute when it
comes to politics in some sense
they all seem
unable to realize
how monstrously unaffected of a
significant portion of the trump base is
by the things that actually take place
go all the way back to grab him by the
you know what and that tape it almost
seems quaint and naive in some weird way
to think back to when we thought wow
trump's primary candidacy it's got to be
over right i mean grab them by the
you-know-what you can just do what you
want and all these allegations
it didn't matter anymore
it didn't matter and uh
it is a monstrous base and if we've
learned one thing it's that if you
overestimate the morality and
intelligence of the trump base you end
up being wrong you end up disappointed
or in places you don't necessarily
expect to be and that's what happened to
lindsey graham it's what happened to
kevin mccarthy it's what happened to
mitch mcconnell they expected at some
point their base would wake up to the
madman that was trump and they never did
and these are their constituents
we have been talking now for over a week
about the possible
unintended or maybe intended but
unexpected or maybe intended and
expected consequences of what we believe
is the forthcoming supreme court ruling
overturning roe v wade and we said well
they'll probably try coming for gay
marriage they'll probably try coming for
co-payment free contraceptives they're
going to try these things and we've
since heard from the texas governor of
uh um the republican governor of texas
greg abbott that they want to come for
the supreme court decision that says the
children of undocumented immigrants have
to be allowed to go to public school
they want to end that
um and we've heard all these different
things i have a very very dangerous uh
example of this for you today
anti-choice activist abby johnson
appeared with radical right conspiracy
theorist stu peters
and previewed the idea of executions of
abortion providers right
if you believe in the death penalty
and you believe abortion is murder
and you believe that it is the abortion
provider that is committing the murder
then it would almost logically follow
that you would say well we've got to put
the abortion providers to death now as a
reminder stu peters the guy on the left
of your screen if you're watching today
he is the same guy who once had either
the flu or covet
and he claimed
that
he was targeted by a bio weapon because
he's against vaccines
instead of just being like well actually
the simplest thing is i got the thing
i'm not vaccinated against that that
actually makes a lot more sense okay so
it's stu peter's interviewing abby
johnson
when they say this stuff we should be
listening to them okay so abortion is
illegal in my state
and that's great when roe is overturned
but what does that actually mean
it means that it's murder
it's murder and
we need a murderer then it needs to be
treated like mercy that's right and we
need a governor with the balls to stand
up and say that
i will bulldoze every single planned
parenthood facility in my state i will
bulldoze any facility that facilitates
this murder of unborn babies
okay now
this is not
this is not merely something that they
say
there have been
dozens or hundreds of acts of vandalism
violence and terror
at family planning clinics across the
country
and abortion doctors have also been
murdered
okay so these are not idle threats and
listen to the words that they're using
pre-born real living people
i will make it a criminal offense to
fund anybody that does this and if you
if you found out funding murder or
carrying out murder you will be executed
period
that's what needs to happen
they need to be indicted and they need
to be tried and they need to be executed
now before we go on to the civil war
part that they talk about
um
there are some on the radical
anti-choice right
who say
try and execute
the abortion providers
there are others who go further and say
execute the mother as well because
ultimately she's consenting to the
procedure
that's that's a controversial position
even among the rights some on the right
say no the women are the victims so you
don't go after them and there's
it's a fraught question because
politically
there are problems on both sides of that
it's a crazy conversation i'm acting
like it's a rational conversation it's
not but certainly execute the abortion
doctors they mostly feel pretty good
about let's move on to the next section
now it's a war over
uh
slavery right why because
there was a group of people
who were seen and treated as sub-human
and right now
in our country
there is a group of people who are seen
and treated as sub-human now understand
she's talking about fetuses as a group
of people
that is part of how they identify with
this issue
i mean we are in our society at war
but
maybe it means more than that
and maybe it should
if there was ever a time if there was
ever an issue
for us to
you know
actually go to war over wow you know if
there was ever a time when this becomes
illegal
and and if these clinics
try to remain open
and kill these babies
then maybe direct action needs to take
place
that's right
they're talking about a civil war
they're talking about violence by the
way at the bottom of the screen i don't
know if you can see this it says
the underbelly of the soros plan to kill
american babies so
it's never a good story on these right
wing channels unless you can somehow
involve george soros in it as well
this is the right wing wet dream killing
abortion providers legally through the
death penalty okay and
a civil war
this is they're not kidding
and hopefully this will never happen but
they're telling the truth that they
would like to see it happen and we know
there is willingness to do violence to
do
uh to do murder from the anti-choice
right they've killed people dr george
tiller
family planning doctor we've talked
about it we covered it when it took
place i don't remember what year it was
was it
uh 2012. let me let me be clear on that
george tiller let me make sure i know
2009 sorry
2009 in wichita kansas george tiller was
shot dead by anti-choice activists
and uh i recently appeared on the the
daily wires michael knowles show again
to talk about uh this issue of abortion
and we're going to be publishing that
soon and you will see the way in which
these people talk about this issue
incites violence
it incites violence and uh
this issue is not going away anytime
soon we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 david p
um i got a call this is pretty
interesting there's a caller who isn't
happy with an anti-death penalty
argument that i guess i made at some
point take a listen to this this is very
interesting
david you did it again on this on
today's show
um
the death penalty
arguing that we sometimes kill the wrong
people is not an argument against the
death penalty dude that's an argument
against the judicial judicial system
that is not a
argument against the death penalty just
like i've heard you say
it actually cost more
to administer the death penalty than it
does to keep somebody alive
okay that's an argument against like
government bureaucracy that is not an
argument against the death penalty
please state a good argument against the
death penalty a moral one okay so uh the
the claim that the caller is making is
that
me being against the death penalty in
part because we execute innocent people
isn't a good argument against the
morality of the death penalty it's an
argument just against
government being unable to cert to
decide for sure to know for sure whether
someone is actually guilty i actually
disagree with this caller i think all of
these are valid arguments against the
death penalty
some want to restrict arguments against
the death penalty only to why it's wrong
to have it
assuming we could execute it perfectly
but the the reality is we live in the
real world and so we have to be able to
consider these other arguments so the
main argument for me being against the
death penalty is that i believe it is
wrong for the government to put people
to death i believe it is wrong for the
government or the state to say well you
killed someone so now we kill you i i
think it's beneath us i think it's
retrograde i think it's antiquated i
think it's cruel and unusual
so that's the main reason i'm against
the death penalty it shouldn't be the
business of the government to be putting
people to death in addition to that we
also have to consider
the justice system isn't perfect and we
never know in all cases we we i can't
imagine we would ever be at 100 percent
only guilty people get convicted and so
that's another reason because it is
irreversible the death penalty is
irreversible and we want to maintain
because any justice system sometimes
makes makes mistakes i would rather be
able to release someone from a life
sentence if they didn't really do it
than kill them
in addition there's the fiscal
conservatism argument where it costs
more
to put someone on death row and
ultimately carry out the execution so if
you care about that that's also an
argument we also so all of these things
are valid arguments by itself
i agree saying the death penalty should
be abolished because sometimes we kill
innocent people i'm with you by itself
that's not a strong enough argument
but it's fine to include it as part part
of a bigger picture about the death
penalty and its problems and there's
other issues as well which i've brought
up in the past about the death penalty
so i respectfully disagree with the
caller
that it's not a valid component of
opposition to the death penalty but by
itself it is not nearly strong enough
let me know your thoughts we have a
great bonus show for you today the bill
to codify abortion protections has
failed in the senate the baby formula
shortage is making many parents very
anxious and we will talk about
thailand's new plan remember trump calls
it thailand i call it thailand to give
away a million free cannabis plants to
households what are they up to and why
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below